uh any apologies I have one here from
councilor Barry Stewart and I believe
everyone else is present can I have a
mover the apology accepted please Ian
pottinger and seconded from uh Mayor Rob
Scott
um are there any Declarations of
interest for the meeting today
appear to be none
first item on the agenda is the
confirmation of minutes of the waste
Advisory Group meeting held on Monday
the 26th of June uh there any questions
errors or no missions that people wish
to raise in relation to those please
foreign
to be none can I have a mover and a
secondary that they are a true and
correct copy
thank you Ian and the second uh uh
that's from me being Bell
uh all those in favor say aye against
carried
the
um next item on the agenda is Enviro
schools and we have a presentation a
copy of which appears on your agenda at
page 21
so if the two people come forward please
to the cheers and make your presentation
and welcome
now thank you my name is uh Josh
Sullivan on senior education advisor
environment Southland
um
scene from environment Southland
and so today we just wanted to discuss
the opportunity to work closer with our
district councils around the waste
education that we're already doing
within our schools
so
um just to start off we just want to
acknowledge the support we have received
over the last uh 20 years so all our
district councils giving us that funding
to continue our program and keep growing
and developing as we have
um to the point now that we've got 56
and buyer schools that are sort of we
work with on a regular basis
today is uh to discuss how we can sort
of work closer together within the waste
space we realize that waste education is
a big part of our program and it's also
a growing area
um so we would just like to discuss if
these opportunities are the ways that we
can work uh closer and look for more
funding to increase our capacity
um to to get more facilitators to work
right across Southland
so right now within the Environ School
space we've got five theme areas that we
work to so waste is one of those and so
for every school that we work with we
have a folder full of that information
and so we can be working with school
teachers students and Community groups
alike to be sharing
um some of the resources that we have
available
so when we work with these uh schools
we're trying to put time into the
uh the teaching staff the Board of
Trustees and the principals so everyone
has a holistic approach to how Waste
Management can look within in the school
and we hope and that'll spreads into the
wider Community each School works
um
over a uh on a journey so they work from
one to eight years as as part of the
Empire schools program
we aim to be spending around three days
per week within schools right across
Southland so that's closing schools down
at Half Moon Bay right up to fjordland
and so right now we have two full-time
facilitators working 37.5 hours a week
but as you can imagine uh that's a lot
of work for two people
um because the Enviro schools is a
national program we've got around 135
facilitators working around the country
so we've got great opportunity to work
with
um some other facilitators that have got
just as much experience as ourselves and
so we can feed into the
um educational resources that we have
available on our websites and talking to
those some other facilitators so we've
got a great opportunity to network and
grow the program just by the support
we're already receiving on a national
level
as well as
um leaning on some of our other
facilitators we can also run a number of
workshops and for those people who've
had a look at our PowerPoint
presentation we can run workshops in the
waste baseball caretakers teachers
students and community members alike so
our largest event is our regional hilly
and that attracts around 200 students
per year to those towards the end of the
year and we also run a number of smaller
workshops during the year as well for
students and teachers alike
and I think it's time to hand over to
any questions about the program
any questions
you
now thanks chair
um look one of the biggest problems we
face with recycling is contamination and
and
we keep hearing about education we need
to educate the public now obviously uh
Enviro schools goes through the schools
now what he what are you guys doing or
are you the appropriate mechanism to
educate obviously kids who can educate
their families now it's about how to
recycle about the cleanliness what
products mainly about cleanliness that's
the problem we're getting we're getting
horrific stuff being dumped in the
elegant right and it's it's it's a
shocker yeah now I'm all favor of a more
drastic policing but
um sort of thing where you inspect bins
and you read card people but but I've
been asked to sit back and look at
education right and uh that well to me
that's a good way of educating people
you do it with parking fines and that's
important but yeah anyway getting back
to kids so you if you've got anything in
your program
that tells them how to do proper
recycling like wash out your milk bottle
clean all the meat trays
um you know keep it clean yeah so um
it's a good question so we we work with
Early Childhood centers so our education
starts at you know in the early Early
Childhood Center so our facilitators
we've got five different facilitators
here so we're working at the youngest
age groups right through to primary and
we've got transitional resources and
then into secondary school so so in
those beginning stages we um are talking
to those young tamariki but we're also
sending letters home as well so you're
informing the students what age group is
that sorry so they're Early Childhood so
you also want to one to five and then
sort of yep yeah that is young but you
remember you also have the opportunity
to feed into the parents right
um because they're coming in regularly
we run events and we're always asking um
parents and community members to come
along to those events plus we're sending
information home to them as well
um and so that's in in the early stages
but then that information then feeds
into the primary school which we're
doing a lot more time in tune so we're
working with the students and again
bringing in the parents to those
um so you have material yep so each
School each teacher gets a folder like
that yeah and are they teaching it
is actually being taught yep cleanliness
everything like that yep yep so you
should be able to uh go into one of our
virus schools and just talk about you
know what are you doing what does it
look like what does waste look like what
does waste management look like you know
and they should be able to talk about
that so obviously schools have
their own recycle bins
so do they practice what they preach do
you you know I mean it's a great thing
yeah they should be able to take their
recycle bin into a classroom dump it on
the floor and it should be nice and
clean and put it back in
yeah so you know we can do waste Audits
and so it's that opportunity to go well
where is this waste coming from how are
we creating waste and what do we do with
it and so that is part of that education
of breaking it down going where is the
largest volume of waste coming from
right now within the school space and so
it's making sure that students are aware
and teachers and
um in the community is aware of where
that waste is so that is part of the
program and the other my last question
is
um wastenet has a budget for Education
yep
that's why I asked about you being uh
the appropriate mechanism for us to
invest in I do you with more funds could
you could you actually achieve more well
I can show you what we're achieving now
you know we've got some we've got
concrete evidence and I'll put that in
the PowerPoint of what we're achieving
now with the um with two facilitators
but you've got to remember environments
out and from the point of view
environment Southland we've got 200
staff and this is our strength is that
designed the two of us in the in the
full-time role as Educators but then we
can lean on science monitoring
biodiversity we've got 200 other staff
that we work very closely with and come
and support the program
um and so and so that's what we're
saying is that if the opportunity to
work closer together we can expand the
program
through what we've already got from an
environmental health and point of view
the staff there okay thanks
any other questions are up just one on
the I'll say you've got sort of under
half of the the schools do you have
capacity to do more of the schools where
you kind of get with those two two staff
um you're right now worth the amount of
time that we're spending in schools we
would be
um at capacity
um just by the time we run workshops and
supporting the schools we already have
and so you know if you're talking about
12 to 15 schools that we're we're
supporting then you know that's a busy
space in terms of supporting you know
not just the students but the Board of
Trustees the principals and the staff as
well so yeah
at a reasonable speed around yeah so
we've got schools uh in Gore fjordland
Stewart Island so we we um we try our
best to cover all of our Southland
Christine thank you um thank you Josh
for your presentation
um I was able to go to one of your
courses where you bought a number of
schools together last year
which was um yeah really informative
thank you the the question I have is I
noticed the increasing litter around the
sides of our roads and I wonder what the
relationship is to what we're seeing to
what you're teaching at the you know at
the um early childhood but also at the
school level with the students yeah
thinking the long term kind of outcome
as well yeah so we
we are looking at it and from a holistic
point of view you may remember
um we had a strong microplastics program
with wastenet as the last few years and
so we're looking at waste not only on
the size of roads but also in our
waterways and so there's a huge amount
of learning and education that needs to
be done across Southland I'm the first
one to acknowledge that
um
but you know trying to find those
opportunities to work with those
teachers in those schools to show them
the amount of waste that's already
within our community and how to reduce
that is um part of what we're offering
in those schools and so we can give you
um examples of handful of schools
they're doing an amazing job with Waste
Management
but it's probably small scale if you're
talking across Southland so it's an
opportunity to increase what we're all
doing you know with the resourcing that
we have
um because right now our our program is
limited to to how much resourcing we can
put into those schools
um
and run the larger programs as well or
the interview hilly that you know you
came along to so we've got all the
resources here but it's a staffing issue
that we're facing to do more to reduce
the amount of waste that we're seeing
across Southland
this question I guess comes from
um lack of knowledge but to what extent
do you work in with the
staff of the other councils or with the
wastenet focused staff of invercargill
um it has been in a limited capacity I
know there's been a number of staff
changes and so uh
um I started this role when Donna
Peterson I think was just leaving
um so most of the work has been sitting
alongside
um
uh the Polytech
um which had already a close
relationship with wastenet
um so it was a link through that so
right now I'm working with Jackie Nelson
um so I haven't had too much opportunity
to work alongside wasting it yet but I'm
hoping that's going to change in the
future
so
are there some areas where we can be of
of assistance to you
so from what I've been reading so far
you've
um you've hired uh waste rewinder and so
we because
waste free wanders coming in to do waste
education from out of Southland we see
ourselves as working alongside what
she's already delivering
um and so that's the presentation that
she's she's got set up across Southland
and so because that's sort of stepping
into school stepping out
in the background we are the ones that
are sort of coming in working two to
three days a week with those schools
that um that waste free Wanda is already
working in so we can build up the
cementing that relationship reinforcing
what
uh Raceway wander is already talking
about and how schools deliver some of
those messages that that partnership was
already wasteful Wanderers already
offering so we see our strengthening
what has already been delivered
in in the other feedback
sorry just for just for clarification on
that so are you suggesting that it would
be best to invest more into Enviro
schools than waste Rwanda and you guys
would pick up the program is that
so you can be brutal that's yeah yeah no
it's a good question that's a good
question so um so we're yeah so we're
asking for
um funding for another facilitator to to
sit alongside what we're already
delivering
um
because the challenge is when you've got
someone coming from out of town
my personal point of view is that's
going to be a there's limited capacity
in terms of making sure that messages
is going to be delivered right across
Southland on a long-term basis
there is impact for that
um
for that then and there when they're
when that person is doing the
presentation but we're working in
schools for a number of years so we're
doing that long-term relationship
building which is crucial for whatever
you're teaching is making sure that
those students are really aware who you
are how you operate them those messages
so they feel comfortable to ask those
questions and that is why Enviro schools
has been operating for 20 years down
here because we've built up long-term
relationships with the schools that
we've been in
okay
thank you for your honesty thank you I'm
just wondering from what you're
indicating that we're at risk of
providing a lot of support into the same
schools and there's a huge gap out there
with your schools for various reasons
find it difficult to be involved and if
that's the case what is it going to take
or how would
um I guess that it should be yeah so we
offer Enviro schools as one part of our
education program the other part is we
offer Environmental Education like
holistic Environmental Education so any
school can contact us which they do and
we can go into those schools and and
offer a
um a program around waste or pest
control or biodiversity and so we've got
sort of three main arms of Education
that we offer which is envira schools
Environmental Education and we've got a
planting site down at the wa I hope I
that we plant on and so we invite any
schools along to planting days but we
can also run programs for Waste
education for any school and we've got
schools that are contacted us on a daily
basis that sit outside and borrow
schools that we offer programs to you
and that again we can do that because
we've got those 200 odd staff and
environment Southland that support us in
that space
um
that resists this opportunity I see
there's a item there on microplastics
yes
now
right you're aware that um out of a b
lime
they take their lead shades
and it currently goes to our wastewater
treatment plant
they Purdue proposed a scheme where they
can remove
through some scientific method
remove the microplastics
[Music]
but
they have to get consent to do that yeah
so you guys in favor of that
um I'd need to learn more about it like
this is the first time I've heard that
so
yeah I just I'm asking the question
because there could be a problem there
right
I mean Leone might be able to speak a
bit more do you know more about it no
I'm not involved in that that part of it
at all but you would see it as a good
thing
because obviously down at the wastewater
treatment plant they can't
a bad thing to remove your microphone
microbistics no no you would think that
if they were doing that yeah
so that consent process is yeah in a
different department to us and then it
would
um rely on on the AE that goes with the
application right
it is incredible though you know when we
are working with Community groups and
schools
um the lack of knowledge and information
around microplastics and waterways
um and so you know part of the program
where we're running with
um tip cooking air and other other
community groups there's just
understanding microplastics and how it's
getting into our waterways like there's
a huge amount of
um lack of knowledge around that you
know because it was just making the
invisible visible and that is that was
why that program was such a success
because people were starting to realize
just how much uh plastic was in there
that they just couldn't see oh you know
I totally agree and it was up to me when
we learned about it yeah as well now I'm
just wondering why why environment South
in May no we want to hold it up that's
all but you're obviously a different
department different yeah different
departments so it's hard to okay yeah
all right that's a question
in any further comment from coming to
the staff question thanks if that's okay
um I know you're working with Jackie but
I just thought um it might be worth just
having a discussion here you spoke about
the um fact that there's some other
councils that are asking you around
waste specific programs my understanding
is generally Enviro schools is quite a
broad program with quite a lot of the
three Waters sort of initial Focus do
you actually have any waste specific
programs that are up and running for
other councils at this stage or is that
just something that you're looking to
step into
um yeah so we have
so through through our theme areas we've
got a full program in there that you can
already deliver so teachers can pick up
that they can choose the waste zero
waste theme area and they can have
actual examples of how to deliver that
in the classroom if we're not there and
so
um what we what we're trying to show is
that we can we can open the door we can
show them those resources and how to use
them but then we're handing it back to
the class the teachers in those schools
so they can deliver that program
um because we just don't have the
capacity to be going around all the
schools but we've got the resources
available for them to use them
themselves
so what I'm I guess I'm questioning is
if you had more resource what would that
mean differently in how you would
deliver waste programs as opposed to the
broader and virus schools program so
that would
um look like getting across more schools
or there may be areas within
um Southland that we really need to
Target
uh you know is there certain schools
that require a lot more support and so
you could put more time into those
schools to really Target the waste
issues that are down there or it could
be that we run more larger scale
presentations so we can bring in you
know two to three hundred students at a
time
and look at some of the solutions around
Waste Management
they would appear to take care of all
the questions that people have so uh
Josh and the only thank you for coming
in
um I think that is an informative
reinforcement of some of the work that
you've been doing for for a long period
of time so we have a recommendation in
the report that
um that the information be received can
I have a mover and a second
please
rob moved in seconded all those in favor
say aye against carried so
um thank you Josh thank you leonie thank
you very much
we will move on to the next item in the
agenda which appears at page 39
which is an update on the waste action
um sorry on uh on page 32 uh the
Wasteland full performance data so there
is a report that's been circulated
since the report came out is there any
additional information the staff need to
draw to our attention
no any questions arising from that
report please
Ian look just curious around the figures
for
um waste diversion from landfill and
Gore is a Shining Light there when it
comes to clean fill now obviously is
there a big project going on that you're
that you've got clean film and
you found a site for it somewhere and
that's counted as waste diversion or
seems an unusual one clean fill to
actually have
there but obviously
um
some people send it to to landfill can I
have some some a bit more detail on that
it just stands out
um cool stuff out to help please
uh thank you through the cheer
um you said our Landfill closed landfill
sites at
um the gore transfer station we uh
undertaking a rehabilitation program uh
for that and so a lot of the the clean
feel from our district goes to there and
is used to
um
rehabilitate that site and fill some of
the lower areas with a plan to make that
a um I guess a biodiversity area that
can be used by residents with walking
past and stuff going through it so it's
been a process that's been ongoing since
our our Landfill closed
I mean I mean that's really good but
it's also alarming to know that that
um and the question has to be asked does
ICC and SDC
have
places that clean field can go to
projects do we have that I mean there
should be none going to landfill
do we have do we have available you know
if you've got a construction site with
cleanfeld
and they ring up where can I dump this
do we have that yes so in term From
icc's perspective
um ICC uses the landfill at timpanies
for clean fill type items
um we did used to take more out there
but with tightening up around clean fill
regulations about six months ago we
started reducing what we were taking out
there
um something that we want to look at
more for ICC though is how our transfer
stations can be developed to do more of
that diversion not just clean fill but
more more broadly I don't think that
we're diverting as much at the transfer
stations as we could potentially could
be so a piece of work that we need to do
for ICC so just to get this right can
someone please explain what clean fill
actually is you know because I'm just
I've got a mix mixed view in my mind
um I'm not a clean fill expert but there
are um legislative guidelines that are
put out by MFE around exactly what um
clean fill consists of the example I'd
give is that we used to
um clean Phil Once Upon a Time the
crushed glass
um we're not able to do that anymore
because it doesn't meet the MFE
definition
um it's something that I need to
circulate after the meeting though as it
is quite complicated I don't have a very
simple answer for you Council it's just
that obviously if we've got graphs and
figures and data on it it's nice to know
I mean it it's a standout thing we're
saying we're diverting it but we don't
know what it is so that's what I'm
trying to find out
what is it we're diverting
you know what is the actual product yep
so I can circulate the what is the
definition of clean fill after the fact
yeah because it's hard to imagine
someone dumping a whole load of soil
into a into a landfill just on a quick
Google search clean for comprises of
dirts I mean concrete gravel brick
topsoil sand and rubber yeah so it
sounds like yeah and that's nice um
degradable material so
um green waste and the like yeah yeah
yeah so I imagine that
yeah if you clean the site like you're
doing at Gore with that reconstructing
that it's all usable
so I just yeah I'm just trying to work
out what clean fill obviously we are
sending like for ICC 53 tons
to
landfill it may be Grant can class yeah
just in 2000 District Council we don't
have a lot of Greenfield sites very few
but we're looking they're to be part of
our amp discussions
um a lot of people actually just get
consents for Greenfield sites uh clean
film sorry where they can and that so
there will be
contractors for instance doing roading
in the light they'll go and find a site
go to the whichever council is
appropriate and get a consent to dump
that material when that keeps it out of
out of the landfill because it's so
expensive so they try they try to do it
that way okay so obviously with Aaron's
point you have to have that
analyzed someone would have to go yeah
it means clean film
it meets these regulations that came in
six months ago you can't just go and
dump it it's more around the clean fill
sites um have been I guess getting a
little bit more up to speed around
what's acceptable to stay within their
consent limits
um so that's where the discussions for
ICC were were prompted
was actually through the clean fill
landfill that we were going to
um starting to reduce what they were
accepting
I guess the the
um uh positive thing to note I guess in
the gore situation is that it's been
channeled in a way that's a benefit uh
helping tied up that site
and also in terms of that report it
acknowledges uh contrary to what's
recently been in the paper that Gore
does do recycling of of a number of
different products
um so any other questions arising from
the report
just on a clean field just to clarify so
that doesn't attract any of the levies
is that a safe assumption or are they
still all movies payables on claimful
Jason helped to help us there I would
think that since a rehabilitation of the
site that it wouldn't
and I think it it's more of the question
is whether you know if it's going to
landfill then you're still going to have
you're still going to be paying charges
on those levies um so
um ideally you wouldn't be sending in if
you can but
[Music]
all right any other feedback Ian yeah
just still on there so it wouldn't I
mean obviously flood protection we've
got flood Banks all along our rivers and
bits and pieces but we're not completely
finished yet so wouldn't that be an
appropriate use
for clean pill
[Music]
um
you know and and have a program that and
it's free I mean it provides a solution
for the person who's cleared aside
but it provides effects for us when
we're not having to try and dig up new
material so
if we got if we got flood protection
plans and stuff still on our pipeline I
think and I don't want to speak on
behalf of star but I think flatbanks are
in could be complicated in terms of what
material they need to contain
yeah yeah yeah
Rebels and
and uh
Madden soil so that's quite a different
quite a different technique too yeah
right engineer
all right any other feedback
appears to be none so we have a
recommendation that the report be
received and the waste Advisory Group
note the waste still in full and
recycling data and Trend Trends can I
have a mover and a second uh for that
please uh so
um
may have been in and Ian's second uh all
those in favor say aye against carried
item six which is Page 39 is an update
on the waste action plans just through
to page 39
uh is there anything further from staff
wish to add to the report
yes
um I'd just like to introduce this
particular report
um we've had a a few comments made
around
um not just the elected members on the
waste Advisory Group but also um of the
councils in general
um still not being quite clear around
what what wasted is actually delivering
at the moment all of these activities
are in the waste activity plan
um but a plus a little bit more but we
thought that it was probably worth
trying to pull together a reasonably
simple couple of pager that brought the
key items front of mind and a quick
update on those
um I guess would be interested for any
feedback around whether that's helpful
any comments and feedback uh Ian
um just going to the bottom left hand
box on Organics business case now can
you talk me through please the
application form is now complete and
ready for filing what I'm just trying to
understand what that is
what's an application form
and where's your fault so we spoke at
the last wastenet meeting apologies we
could have included some more detail
there about the fact that we needed to
finalize the application for funding
with MFE
um that's the application for that
funding we can receive up to 75 funding
from MFE to complete that business case
okay and the business cases for
for what obviously policies sent to
consultant so this is about
um so this is this is around a organic
strategy for Southland
um focused on essentially how we would
potentially collect that but very much
focused around what that secondary
processing would look like once as we
know at the moment central government
have set that timeline out for
collection of of food waste
um what we need to do as Southland
councils is decide once that actually
that Collection comes into force uh what
actually happens to our Organics once we
collect it so do we wind up with a
digester based plant do we go to
um you know composting tunnel type
systems it's also a large piece of work
that is I guess being completed by
councils around the country at the
moment as councils attempt to to move
food waste and Organics in general out
of landfills from our perspective
although we don't have it we're not an
early adopter in Southland there are
other private Enterprises at the moment
that are interested in what they can do
to divert their own green waste and they
are coming to
wastenet asking for guidance in that
space one of the key things for us is to
be able to do some initial work at least
in that space so that we're able to give
some good direction for where Southland
would like to go in this space
okay just that that obviously okay we've
got 20 30 from the government's point of
view but in our discussion with the
public and our consultation for ltp it
was clearly fed back to us that
um the people of Cargill don't really
want a separate bin
um they're saying hey we're keen to
compost we're keen to be proactive in
this and not
not have to pay not have to pay because
it's going to cost to put it in a
collection ban and then it goes off to
some company or something who turns it
into compost you know and sells it
um so our feedback is no we don't we
don't want to do that we want a
community-based thing so we in our in
our plans are we looking at the
community-based option
otherwise these you know having
consultation with the public is pretty
pointless if we don't follow on what
they're asking for
so waste metal obviously the waste net
staff will take the direction from
wastenet governance around what we want
to do in this space is at this stage
staff's Direction has been around there
is a legislative mandate at the moment
that we're working to whether that
changes in the future may or may not be
the case but at the moment their whilst
there is 75 funding on the table there
was money that was put into the budget
for wastenet at the start of the year to
fund that remaining money and do a
business case as it's currently sitting
in the action plan and in the budget
staff are progressing with it at this
stage unless we get advised to do
otherwise well okay I'm just wondering
how our ltp feeds into wastenet you know
obviously all those discussions we've
had does that feed it you know through
our it feeds in from the three different
councils will obviously staff will
working together will bring the
different perspectives of their
different councils but at the moment it
is a wastenet activity until we're told
otherwise okay
thank you any other Rob and Christine
just a further question to that look so
would there be potentially funding
available
for local initiatives for the likes of
compost things
via waste me is that something that made
um you'll see that there's a later paper
around Community grants we have started
that process and and that could fund
initiatives like that however I'd note
it's only a fifty thousand dollar grant
program at the moment so there's not a
huge amount of money of money available
at this stage
in total for the entire program and
that's what we approved in the budget
and just a further question just while
I'm here I'm not related to that but
that um waste free one they're just
given that first presentation that we
had
um and I haven't had a chance to
actually look at their
um the schools that it whether we've got
double handling of Western wonder and
Enviro South going to school and there's
another school potentially missing out
on both so I just wonder if it's worth
looking at
the schools that we actually focusing on
some of the schools that don't have the
Enviro South link so we're getting a
wider cover of the education piece
or whether it's too late to make any of
those changes that they are required
um so as uh Josh from environment
Southland advised he's currently linking
in with Jackie Nelson who works for
wastenet
um Jackie's got the waste free Wonder
schools scheduled
um and then she'll be linking in
um in with environment Southland as I
noted though at the moment the
environment's Southland program is a lot
broader program than just waste but
you're right regardless it would be nice
if they were not targeting the same
schools and we were able to get that
broader diversion
um and we'll we'll work with environment
Southland to see if we can achieve that
noting that wastenet's not currently
funding them though
Christine
I just want to notice positive to see
the report here on the battery disposal
facility given what we're here as maybe
nine with the risk not just the
Machinery but also people operate in a
bit Machinery I guess it's not only
um Southland that will be looking at
options around battery disposal
you can't just have the mic closer
so I'm not sure if everyone heard that
or not
yeah and I think there's quite a few
um of these schemes that are being run
with um private in partnership with
private Enterprise like miter 10 around
the country
um unfortunately it hasn't seemed to
reach as far south as Southland
um which is where we need to get that
moving down here so that's the um one of
the pieces of work that the team are
focused on at the moment thank you
it will be transportation to
Christchurch
it's around who can actually process the
batteries at end of life and where the
nearest place to do that is because they
are still a hazardous material
in
um
about curbside standardization for
recycling now the government have
said one two and five
is this uh is this a solid rule or do we
have flexibility because
um with this plan to macaree where the
uh
that recycle South have they have the
ability to take four
grade four now
where where does the government sit on
us being
so at the moment
um the legislation's been put in place
so that
um we can be sure across the country I
guess that everybody is collecting the
same thing and so that it doesn't matter
whether you've just moved from
Christchurch where you were putting your
recycling out
um and then moved to Southland your
recycling looks the same in both places
um through the consultation process on
this councils did submit around the fact
that obviously there's unique situations
in different parts of the country around
what can be recycled where
um
and the I guess there's still the
opportunity for us to recycle via
drop-off points um those other items and
obviously recycle South have the ability
to recycle more than just those Plastics
ones twos and fives but at the moment
that would have to be a separate
collection to the mixed recycling uh Bin
once those new requirements come in
serious I mean that just seems ludicrous
from the MEP that they've gone one two
five and it's a bit short decided to not
realize that you know these plants and
then there's not to say that a plant's
similar to the one at macaroon where is
going to be set up somewhere else in the
country or maybe even more
um
it just seems totally against what
they're trying to achieve to say no it
must be one two and five and you can't
do four if you want to do four you've
got to take it yourself drive somewhere
and put it in a separate slot as opposed
to Yellow bin now
because obviously we're going to be
rebranding the labeling on our bins to
instruct people
um
and we'll be just saying one two and
five is that what you're saying
once that standardization process comes
in yes we'll be saying one two and five
my understanding not being a Plastics
expert but my understanding is that one
twos and fives make up very much the
Lion's Share of the Plastics in in most
recycling bins around the country and I
have seen some interesting graphs before
around when you take out those other
categories of plastics that you don't
actually drop a significant amount in
that recycling tonnage overall
um I understand it's also to do with if
you can move Plastics into just their
one type of plastic then it's much
easier to have a market for those than
if you have bales of mixed Plastics and
so I understand that's also been part of
the driver from MFE behind trying to
simplify that that message of recycling
less well rather than trying to
potentially recycle everything to a
lesser standard
and if you were calling
um at our last meeting in Memphis made a
presentation
and they demonstrated quite an
inflexible approach on several fronts
when it came to the provisions that have
been put in for a collection of
different types of waste well yeah no no
no I've dealt with me for the last 13
years
Vietnam that's fine uh Rob just a
further question on the battery disposal
um when you're discussing the miter team
I assume that that's miter 10 around the
whole region so we've got TL winter and
Gore and invercargill and not just the
one in invercargill or
no that's right we're looking at it
regionally around how many we can get on
board not saying that we're necessarily
going to be able to get that in every
miter 10 but as many as we can
like it's just a final coming for me
noting the um recent inference in the
media that waste me it's not actually
doing anything and there's there's eight
work streams sitting here in front of me
that I think indicates different to that
and yeah just acknowledge the staff and
the work that is being done
thank you any other comments
uh just around the separate glass
collection investigation um just for
Gore consuming we do separately click
glass standard at the moment is that
investigating a collection of plastics
for us or is it just uh how do we fit
into that investigation
through the chair so yes for we'll be
working with BCL in terms of for us Gore
moving our glass to a blue bin and our
mixed recycling back to uh the yellow
bin to achieve consistency across the
region
all right can I have a uh mover and a
second for the recommendation the report
be received please
um Rob
and Ian seconded all those in favor say
aye against carried
item eight uh that was on page 39 uh
sorry that's six I need to get my
glasses cleaned seven wastenet education
Community activity updates on page 42.
um
any further update from staff in terms
of since that report none any questions
coming from the floor please Ian
um look the waste isn't getting any
cleaner
um so what what what do we need to do
the recycling sorry the recycling
and and this is really a significant
issue that invercargill have identified
before absolutely the contamination
that's occurring and from our previous
meetings we've discussed probably
two-fold approach one is education and
the second is enforcement well the
education is not working yeah so we need
to further at the
uh I don't know I thought I thought we
had another six months of Education we
were told
as can I have uh just a timeline on when
education becomes
end of life or we need to double up with
enforcement
because education is not working
my my understanding was that when it
came up the indication was that a period
of a number of months is required before
um or once a new system is being adopted
uh to bring people up to speed uh prior
to taking more enforcement action so
step by step what what you've and that's
with the system we've got now and and
moving forward with further bins further
education is required from that is there
anything staff want to add to that
I think in terms of the discussion we're
having later there's an issue there that
that does need to be talked about but
Jason
yeah I guess just from a
uh an outsider's point of view coming
into and seeing the um the wasting it
operations from a staff level I think
it's important to note that
um we've only sort of recently had
Jackie back in the role oh Jackie come
into the waste education space
um and since then there had been
um nobody in that position nearing and
so I guess it's a state that you know
things aren't working I mean it's only
really just kicked into gear um I think
it's
um yeah like I totally agree there's an
ongoing issue around contamination but
we're going to struggle to change that
overnight just through education I get
we want to go with the
um in terms of the fact there's a stick
component to that also but I think it's
hard to I just it's hard to say that
we're going to see that there will be a
bit of lag time in terms of the work
that Jackie's starting to drive in the
community through this year's business
plan to try and achieve some positive
outcomes from an educational point of
view so in 2011 we had enforcement
um and we had this anti-education at the
same time but for some reason the
enforcement
component fell away
I mean we've previously had it and I'm
not sure it was under the invercargill
city council bylaw for solid waste that
wasn't forced at the time I was at a
waste net level uh there is a wastenet
um policy in place but the invercargill
City by law has lapsed
and what you're indicating is that there
is a need for all three councils to have
in place and up to date by law I wasn't
aware that we stopped
inspections for that reason
through you Mr chair we we've got the
education program for 23 24 as we
discussed I think at the last meeting
and we're going to go and been
inspection again in the 24-25 year
that's how we put out our financials and
our education and inspections and we're
getting some data so we know where to go
and have a look once we get some good
data through Jackie and the team we'll
know which parts of town and parts of
the province of the big offenders and
then we'll go some do some work there
but we've got to get we've got to get
some data to know where to go and hit
first
okay so the actual bin inspection
process would that be done obviously if
you do it with
in-house and it used to be in-house ICC
did I don't don't know what happened
with Gore and SDC but then there's been
an offer from uh a separate contractor
to do it on our behalf now which line
are you looking at
so there's a couple of pieces to this
one is around the in you know and I'm
not exactly sure of how we enforced it
in 2011.
um but one of the concerns that we've
spoken about at the waste net table is
that there are councils around the
country that are taking quite Ace you
know Stern approach to contamination to
the point where there's taking away
people's bins and people have to pay a
fine to get their bin back if they're
not doing the right thing
um we there's been a lot of work that's
been done by other councils which we are
confirming for us in Southland at the
moment around the legal enforceability
of doing that because we obviously want
to make sure that anything that we do is
actually backed up
um and and legal That We're Not Making
empty threats
um so that's a another piece of work
that we currently have underway at the
moment is around what that would look
like to make sure that it is actually
enforceable
but also to the point that we've
discussed previously we're kicking off a
new education campaign
um we as staff we have put forward the
view that we needed to essentially
educate people about the fact that you
need to wear seat belts before you go
and start ticketing people for not
wearing seat belts we wanted to take the
same approach to waste
um and at this and and we set the budget
up
um in response to that
um obviously staff can be instructed to
take a different approach
um if required
so I I I I still need clarification if
possible around were we doing it
correctly
at the start back in 2011 would it did
you know Keith has alluded to a a policy
or a bylaw we had that slapsed now
Dewey I mean other councils do it so
they must
and what about SDC and Gore do they need
to is this a wastenet thing or is this
an ICC thing
so each Council holds its own bylaw
um ideally what we would like to do and
we would be looking to do next year is
to start to bring alignment between
those different bylaws so that
everything looks the same
um and then similarly to be able to do
what enforcement steps we would take in
alignment across waste Nets so that
everything is as consistent as possible
across Southland I mean it seems crazy
that MFE have the audacity to say and
dictate one two and five with plastics
and this and that surely the MEP being a
government Department must be able to
you know if you want to ship from
Province to Province and still have the
same rules surely
a nationwide rule
on contamination would make sense and
the laws backing up councils to do it
would make sense it seems that this sort
of fine print and hidden legal uh sort
of sort of black holes seems a real
problem and doesn't like the muv I mean
do we need to ask them
what the hell I mean I'm not sure under
What legislation government could
actually introduce some blinker law
rules will are telling us to put one two
and five in
um yeah in terms of the enforcement side
of it because where there's a bylaw then
the provisions The Local Government Act
apply
um but there is certainly a conversation
we need to have around the table
um once we proceed through the bylaw
stage and it is provided for in the
current budget to look at the bylaw
a fresh but as part of that we need to
have a discussion around the table as to
whether the enforcement of individual
bylaws my understanding is each Council
must have its own bylaw but we can act
jointly in the way that we process the
bylaw and the way we administer it we
need to be talking around the table in
terms of the way enforcement is
undertaken and there needs to be a
consistent approach to that across the
region
so I think what you have highlighted are
issues that we need to work through this
year
um uh and and they're noted in the um
minutes that have been taken so the last
part of the question I'm just waiting on
the answer for was getting through all
the bylaws stuff would this process of
inspection be done by
Council staff or by subcontract that's
that's something that in terms of our
budgets we need to be looking at and
should it be done under the umbrella of
waste Network should it be done as
individual councils again
um that's something that we need to
discuss around the table I can't really
make a decision on
um here today without having all the
information in front of us
well I'm hearing early 2024 for this is
that right
because we don't have and our annual
plans present
Provisions for uh additional bins so
we'll be looking at the next financial
year at the earliest that we can start
to do it and there is part of that then
we need to have a program in place for
the education and we also need in place
by that time
um a a common bylaw
any other comments thank you uh Rob just
a quick comment on the education piece
just um we've got a publication that
goes out to every single ratepayer
called first edition then it might be
worth putting something in there from
from our side to actually start getting
submit messaging across yeah
and I think just further to that Mr
chair as we've staged our ltp program
around the number of people we've
actually got a wasting it to do the work
that's required and getting asked of us
there's only a very small number of
people involved in this compared to
other councils in the country
considerably this
all right any any other comment in terms
of the item seven that's in the agenda
please
if not we have a recommendation the
report be received can I have a move or
Ben sorry just uh just a some more
questions just around the waste free
wander again
um just given the conversation we had
earlier in the piece are we able to get
a report back on how effective the waste
free wonder is actually being I see
there's a questionnaire here
um I think going down the track it's
going to be up to the uh committee to
review whether it is best to continue to
invest in waste free Wonder or to
provide environments envirus schools
with some more funding for that broader
brush approach I just see to their point
earlier
um that one visit to a school
um it's probably less effective than the
consistent ongoing relationship so it
would be good to get those two measured
up if possible
uh and then supplementary to that
um and to to the council's point
um are we able to get a report back as
well on the effectiveness of the
community engagement I see basically the
only indication that we get an
Effectiveness as our own post engagement
here which is 86 which is pretty low and
I understand that it's still getting
going but it would be good to see the
progressive interaction I'm not too sure
how that reporting would look but it
would be good to give us some confidence
uh that that education piece is getting
some sort of result even if it's minimal
um I guess it's to be honest it's
something I'd be interested to
potentially talk to our other teams
across the three different councils
around how we do measure community and
engagement
um as a pipes person I know how we
measure the performance of pipes
um I'm not actually great on how we
measure Community engagement
um so something that we'll um will will
work through I am conscious that we want
to make sure that we give each program
enough time to to run for a while and
then essentially at this stage we'd be
going back and we'd be getting feedback
from the schools around how it worked
and whether they were seeing outcomes
how that then translates into dropping
contamination levels ideally we want to
be tracking that through seeing a
reduction in that contamination but I do
expect that's probably going to take up
to 12 months before we start to see that
starting to drop back but I'll have a
chat
um to at least the ICC
teams in that space I'm not sure what
Gore nsdc have around Community
engagement as to whether they can give
us any direction on early indicators of
whether or not you're you know having
impact in that space
Jason
uh you're through the chair just I think
one of the things you've got to remember
with education too is it's not one
versus the other you know you need a
number of different tools to use and for
example what were is being promoted
through waste for free wonders
considerably different to Enviro schools
virus schools is more of a curriculum
type
based program where you're sort of
focusing on the way ways from what way
through Wanda does is quite a sort of a
targeted engaging with kids trying to
really get them to buy and I think it's
based around a superhero type theme
where she goes in and
um tries to connect with kids so there's
a number of different tools through
education that you need to use grin
there's probably some alignment there
that could be had against across what
virus calls are doing but I'd also just
like to raise that back a couple of
meetings ago we talked about the need to
grow that education space with
minimization waste minimization officer
space to allow us to be doing more
um and that would be something that I
think should still be on the radar as we
as we do this and obviously that's a
question about when you have likes of
envira schools who are
talking about something specific how do
we balance that with what we need as a
region to actually make change on the
ground in terms of some of our issues
such as you know contamination which has
come up can we do that better through
waste minimization offices that are out
there trying to improve things or is it
through an envirus course program or is
it through the combination of education
and enforcement there's a number of
different factors that are going into
this to try and get a positive outcome
for our communities
thank you fully fully understand that um
I guess it's just coming back to council
postinger's Point around you know
there's a whole education here but I
would have to go ahead and believe
councilor passenger and say it's not
working because I have nothing in front
of me that says otherwise
um and just to that
Effectiveness around the way through
Wonder there is a questionnaire here so
I guess it's it's once the program's
been running what those questionnaires
look like and and ultimately what the
teachers think because if they don't
think it's effective then our money's
probably best spent elsewhere into that
continued investment piece as well I
totally agree
um but it'll be good to have some facts
and figures of where we should be
investing and we're not but fully
understand it's difficult to get well it
is and we've just started to get these
education programs up and running again
because I've been they haven't been for
some time so create the staff to get
them up and running uh we probably need
to get a bit of time in that before we
before we can really determine how we
measure a key component is the
appointment of a waste neck man manager
how is that progressing
so there's character that adverts
currently with a recruitment firm as
well as being publicly advertised at the
moment
foreign
for the motion that the report be
received moved by being seconded by Rob
all those in favor say aye uh contrary
against carried
item eight uh waste minimization
Community grants there is a report there
that sets out in a bit more detailer are
there any questions arising from that
report please
I have one in terms of it will close
I'll be open to the public until the
16th of September uh what process is
Then followed does it come back to us as
a group or is there some other process
we need to we're working through that at
the moment we've actually got a staff
meeting on Thursday this week to talk
through next steps with the process how
these are generally run though in terms
of the community Grant programs that I'm
aware of that currently exist within
council is that there's often a mix some
of them go to a full governance board to
decide some are decided at a staff level
and then reported on back to the board
what we need to decide is how we want to
take that approach
Ian
um could it be used if you're at a club
of of any sort
um they wanted to do a cleanup like take
for example
invercargill Sandy Point area you know
which has a huge amount of people
through and there is crap lying around
if they did a big cleanup is that
something that a club could apply to do
and obviously get a a grant you know get
get like as a fundraiser
uh it would all come down to what
applications we receive and then that
committee deciding on which are the most
worthwhile
um applications to go forward with
um depending on how many we get
um obviously if we get less than the
total amount of money available
absolutely
um if we get more than the total number
of of available then we'll be looking at
those priorities and which
um which act proposed activities best
meet the objectives is that letter is
someone raised it before a letter is
getting more prominent
um in those areas and it's a real shame
so
um is litter a waste net
thing or is that more of an individual
Council thing
I mean obviously we're in waste
diversion and all that but do we do
litter or is it not our not in our scope
it's not something that wastenet has had
as a objective the key I'll bring us I
guess back to the key objectives of
wastenet is around having efficient
joint contracts for the management of
waste and recycling so that's the
initial Focus then we obviously have
that education piece around trying to to
minimize to date we haven't had a
Consolidated I guess litter
campaign that we've been looking at okay
so it's really goes to the
infrastructure of each Council I mean
obviously someone could say it it's a
form of waste diversion from landfill I
mean if you put it in your put in the
streets and the bushes it's not going to
landfill but it's it's not Flash and I
I'm doing a lot of walking up the dog at
the moment and I've just it was quite
noticeable out at Sandy Point
and just around our streets the
yeah so uh to date and I'm happy to have
any other comments from other stuff is
that usually we would handle that
through our parks and reserves team our
roading teams for roadside rubbish our
CBD teams for tidy up so it's not a
wasting everything
yeah and that's the same Chris DC
Christine sorry
Mike went I think is a group of councils
we could take a focus on that I mean
strictly speaking it's not on the
parameters of this but it's related
um and it may be that we can't do it but
together focus on that as to whether we
care what kind of can't be interested in
finding out
particularly around the education
component
any other feedback in terms of the
report
um
so we will I guess for the August
meeting
um hear more about that and and the
process going forward so can I have uh
if there's no further comment I'll move
on in a second
um that the information be received
moved in second
yeah Rob thank you all those in favor
say aye against carried
um item nine is merely to note that our
next meeting will be at the 11th of
September at the gore District Council
so that brings us to the end of the
public portion of the agenda
um and I'd like to move that the public
now be excluded from the following parts
of the proceedings namely the items that
are listed in the agenda and the general
subject of matter to be considered by
The public's exclude and the reasons for
it the specific grounds under the local
government and meetings Information Act
are as follows the item is the
presentation on proposed pelletizer
plant and we are going into public
excluded to protect information where
the making of the information
would be likely to be unreasonable to
Prejudice the commercial position of a
person who supplied or subject to the
information
so staff may who are present May remain
as well as we having a presentation
coming from recycle South and that is
um from yourself or just take a short
adjournment for a couple of moments
please and then we'll reconvene